[Música]
en Chile tres carabineros han sido
asesinados en las últimas semanas el
último Daniel Palma en la noche del
miércoles de la semana pasada Esta
última muerte ha acabado con la
paciencia de la sociedad que ve como ha
aumentado la delincuencia y la violencia
en el país esto ha llevado al gobierno
de Gabriel boric a una nueva crisis
empujado por la presión social y de la
derecha en la oposición ha sacado
adelante varias reformas entre las que
se encuentra una para dar mayor potestad
a los carabineros en el uso de las armas
en defensa propia ahora para analizar
las consecuencias de esta situación para
el gobierno hablamos con Rodrigo Bustos
botay director ejecutivo de amnistía
internacional chile Rodrigo buenos días
para usted le doy la bienvenida desde
los estudios de France 24 aquí en Bogotá
Hola Muy buenos días Le quiero empezar
planteando la reforma definitiva saldrá
de la mezcla entre las propuestas más
duras de la derecha y los postulados del
gobierno de borich que las ha intentado
suavizar qué potestad tendrán finalmente
los carabineros en el uso de armas y que
otras reformas se aprobarán
Bueno lo primero como como bien ha
señalado esto se da en un contexto donde
han muerto tres carabineros dos
carabineros una carabinera víctima de
homicidio en procedimientos policiales
en las últimas semanas lo cual Por
cierto es es trágico tiene que
investigarse sancionarse y sobre todo
revisar los procedimientos para que los
policías de nuestro país puedan estar
mejor protegido ante acto de
delincuencia por ante la violencia que
que ha ido en aumento dicho esto
la reforma que se ha ido llevando
adelante estas modificaciones legales
primero que nada decirte que se han
llevado adelante
en un clima político donde la
tramitación legislativa se dio muy muy
rápidamente sin querer escuchar a
organizaciones de Derechos Humanos como
internacional como el alto comisionado
de Naciones Unidas y distintos
especialistas expertos en derecho penal
Y eso Por cierto es muy preocupante
porque se trata de problemas que son
complejos y no se pueden resolver de
manera Express simplemente para poder
responder a esta preocupación de la
ciudadanía ahora bien Cuáles son esta
reforma bueno fundamentalmente como bien
señalaste ahí una legítima defensa
privilegiada para el caso en que los
policías tengan que utilizar fuerza
letal en el contexto del ejercicio de
sus funciones se va a presumir
legalmente la licitud de la conducta del
policía
y y en el fondo va a ser muy difícil
probar caso a caso de que el policía no
ha actuado de manera correcta cuando ha
hecho uso de fuerza letal y Rodrigo le
pregunto Precisamente lo que usted me
comentaba que a ustedes internacional no
se les ha escuchado Así como tampoco por
ejemplo a Naciones Unidas sí por qué no
se les escuchó y que le habrían dicho
ustedes a los representantes a chilenos
frente a esta propuesta de reforma de
seguridad
Bueno la verdad es que
enviamos una solicitud por escrito para
en tres ocasiones para poder ser parte
de esta discusión legislativa entendemos
que Naciones Unidas también hizo lo
propio y Simplemente no no se nos
respondió porque como te decía el debate
legislativo se dio en un clima político
donde esta reforma había que aprobarla a
como diera el lugar sin mayor discusión
sin invitar a expertos de en derecho
penal y es una modificación que puede
traer problemas es un cambio legislativo
que parte del supuesto de que los
policías hoy en día están no pueden usar
sus armas prácticamente
porque si no estarían arriesgándose a
condenas permanentemente lo cual es muy
alejado de la realidad la verdad es que
si uno ve la cifra de por ejemplo
denuncia de violación a los Derechos
Humanos ocurría durante 2019 en el
periodo en este in social fueron casi
once mil denuncias por violación a los
derechos humanos y solamente después de
este año y medio tenemos 17 condenas por
lo tanto no hay aquí una penalización
generalizada de los policías que usan la
fuerza ni en contexto de protesta ni en
contexto de procedimiento policial es
normal precisamente Rodrigo usted hacía
referencia al estallido social de 2019
le preguntó Cómo esta reforma puede
afectar al derecho a la manifestación y
a la protesta
puede nosotros creemos que puede
afectarlo porque bueno
está esta modificación que te comentaba
respecto de la legítima defensa
privilegiada pero incluso Rosa hay otra
modificaciones que nada tiene que ver
con la protección de los policías por
ejemplo la figura legal de los apremios
ilegítimos que es el delito a través del
cual se regulan en Chile los tratos
crueles inhumanos y degradantes también
tuvo modificaciones legales en el
contexto de esta reforma legislativa ya
que se eliminó la gravante de custodia
respecto de personas privadas de
libertad y también se establecieron
nuevos requisitos adicionales para que
se configure lo apremio legítimo los
tratos cruella inhumanos degradante y
sabemos que la gran mayoría de los casos
por ejemplo en contexto de del estadio
social fueron tipificados como a premios
ilegítimos por lo tanto si hay una
preocupación de que esta reforma
sí puede afectar la protesta social y en
cambio no no tenga un efecto relevante
es la protección de los policías y en
abordar como corresponde con con mayor
fuerza la delincuencia que tenemos en
Chile precisamente a raíz de lo que
comentan no la delincuencia que tienen
en Chile sino las tasas de delincuencia
de violencia continúan siendo de las más
bajas de la región a pesar del asesinato
de estos a tres policías recientemente
la alarma social está el arma esta
preocupación por la seguridad tiene
fundamentos tiene razón de ser
bueno en este caso en las últimas
semanas esta alarma estuvo motivada por
los los traumático homicidio de tres
funcionarios policiales hay homicidios
que han ido en aumento en algunas
regiones del país especialmente como tú
bien señala Eso sí chile sigue siendo de
los países de América Latina con menores
tasas tanto de homicidio como de delitos
en general ahora bien creemos desde
amnistía que no se trata de minimizar
la necesidad de enfrentar la
delincuencia la delincuencia sobre todo
organizada en narcotráfico Son
problemas que también finalmente afectan
los derechos de las personas sin embargo
lo que se requiere ahí es una policía
que avance en ser más profesional tenga
mejores tecnologías mejor entrenamiento
se fortalezca también todo lo que es su
equipamiento sus protocolo esos son
cambios que irían claramente dirigido a
enfrentar mejor la delincuencia y a
proteger de mejor manera a los policías
y Lamentablemente
los cambios legales que en cambio se han
llevado adelante las últimas semanas
creemos que nos van en absoluto la
dirección correcta de enfrentar la
delincuencia y además pueden tener el
efecto de que pudieran generarse
problemas de violación a los Derechos
Humanos por esta modificaciones legales
que hemos mencionado y Rodrigo
Esta es una reforma una situación que
divide no al gobierno de Gabriel boric
que además tiene muchos miembros que
provienen como el mismo del movimiento
social del movimiento estudiantil es
difícil para El Ejecutivo chileno en la
situación en la que se encuentra
Probablemente sí en el sentido de que
estas reformas que se están llevando
adelante no estaban en el programa de
gobierno
son mociones parlamentarias iniciadas
por un grupo de parlamentarios de la
oposición y lo que sí En cambio estaban
en el programa de gobierno era llevar
adelante una reforma las policías en
particular a la policía de carabineros
de chile esa reforma además hay que
recordar que fue recomendada por parte
de cuatro organismos internacionales por
parte de amnistía internacional y por
parte de otros tres organismos
internacionales que hicieron visitas
chile después del estallido social de
2019 y sin embargo esa reforma policial
después de un año de iniciado el
gobierno del presidente borich sigue
pendiente queremos que se reforma sigue
siendo necesaria
como te decía desde una perspectiva de
tener una policía respetuosa de los
Derechos Humanos como también desde la
perspectiva de tener una policía que
tenga mejores herramientas para
enfrentar el crimen organizado el
narcotráfico que por cierto son desafíos
complejos en una sociedad democrática en
estos momentos sí Rodrigo desafíos
complejos y que comparte no gran parte
de la región Rodrigo Bustos
Lamentablemente se nos acaba el tiempo
pero muchísimas gracias por haber
compartido su análisis y su conocimiento
con nosotros en France 24
Muchísimas gracias a ustedes muy buenos
días
nosotros regresamos en pocos minutos con
más aquí en la segunda media hora de
directo América sigan con nosotros
[Música]